We're living in a very unusual timeline.
My friend's stock car racing league, NASCAR,
has banned the Confederate flag at all events
and properties, period, while the president
of the United States on the same day a rich
guy raised in New York City is loudly defending
Confederate named military bases in the United
States. Says he will not change the names
of those bases and is being called the Confederacy
second president by a Republican group.
So especially for our viewers outside the
U.S., but also for people in the United States,
just as a sort of refresher, the Confederate
flag was the flag of the Confederacy in the
American Civil War. You had the Union versus
the Confederacy. Some called it North versus
South, the Confederacy fighting for slavery.
Sometimes they say they were fighting for
states rights, too, which I always like to
say states rights to continue having legal
slavery, whereas the union was fighting to
abolish slavery. Of course, the union won
and slavery was abolished. And the effects
of slavery, of course, took much longer than
just that war to actually deal with. But there
are parts of this country where Confederate
flags are sometimes also called the rebel
flag. They are revered or fetishized in some
way, even in the sort of hill towns in western
Massachusetts where I went near, where I went
to high school. You would have places just
10 or 15 miles out of North Hampton, Massachusetts,
which was a super liberal little city that,
you know, the guys thought it was cool to
drive into the vocational school with a pickup
truck that bore a Confederate flag on the
back. And there are those who I believe rightly
see it as a symbol of hatred and oppression.
And there are others who say it is a symbol
of history and heritage. But in any case,
it is widely now in popular culture being
eliminated. And I quite frankly, I believe
that it should be. I mean, would we apply,
you know, look at the losers in other conflicts,
losers that are fortunately losers because
they wanted horrible things like could we
say that displaying Nazi flags just because
they lost is just it's history.
Like there was a German military and it's
just wrecking like, okay, guys. It's an extreme
example, but I find it to be in very, very
poor taste. Now, this gets us to NASCAR. NASCAR
in the United States is not known for being
made up of the most progressive people. Now,
I'm not saying NASCAR fans are all racists,
but it's certainly a sport that leans more
conservative in terms of its fan base.
And it's one of the few places where Donald
Trump can actually get himself a crowd that
cheers instead of a crowd that boos. And it
is a place where, unfortunately, Confederate
flags are certainly more common than in other
sports. You don't tend to see Confederate
flags at NBA Games. You don't tend to see
Confederate flags at Major League Soccer matches.
And as far as I know, they wouldn't even be
allowed in. To be perfectly frank. But you
do see them at NASCAR races. Until now, NASCAR
has now banned the display of the Confederate
flag at all events and properties.
And notably, NASCAR also removed its rule
that says racing team members have to stand
for the national anthem. And we've seen a
number of sports leagues now say, you know,
if you don't want to stand, you actually don't
have to stand. So every indication here is
NASCAR sees what's happening nationally since
the killing of George Floyd. Bubba Wallace,
one of their racers, has been very supportive
of drivers. I think they're called has been
shows what I know has been very supportive
of the protests. And they are making a decision
that there is going to be no more Confederate
stuff at their races. Now, is it because.
Everybody involved morally believes that there
shouldn't be Confederate flags.
I don't know. Certainly they've made the business
decision that there will be no more Confederate
flags there. Not everybody's happy. NASCAR
truck series driver Ray Cicarelli Cicarelli
wrote on his Facebook page he's going to quit
after this season because Confederate flags
have been banned. Have fun, buddy. Don't let
the door hit you on the way out. And then
here's the real amazing contrast. Look at
the last 24 hours in NASCAR. And compare that
to the last 24 hours of Trump. Trump putting
out a statement and tweeting that he will
not change the names of Confederacy themed
military bases, saying, quote, It has been
suggested that we should rename as many as
10 of our legendary military bases, such as
Fort Bragg in North Carolina, Fort Hood in
Texas, Fort Benning and Georgia. These monumental
and very powerful bases have become part of
a great American heritage and a history of
winning victory and freedom. The United States
of America trained and deployed. These are
our heroes on these hallowed grounds and won
two world wars. Therefore, my administration
will not even consider the renaming of these
magnificent and fabled military installations.
Our history as the greatest nation in the
world will not be tampered with respect our
military. Now, what's funny about respect
our military is that remember the union won
the civil war, meaning that the military should
be respected. The military that should be
respected is the military that fought against
the Confederacy. Because we won. The union
won. So when you name the four, it's after
the side that lost that was killing the precursor
to our correct military. The Confederacy that
fought for slavery doesn't really make a lot
of sense because you've named Fort's after
people who were against our military. They
did not respect our military. So, listen,
this is not the biggest issue. I don't really
care what the forts are called, although it
doesn't make a lot of sense to me that we
name them after the losers who wanted to keep
slaves, but who would have guessed, as Barack
Obama was leaving office, that during the
subsequent presidential term, NASCAR would
take the more progressive stance of banning
the Confederate flag compared to the president
who defends Confederacy era statues, figures,
heroes, whatever they like to call them. Republican
group. The Lincoln Project, which is a Republican
group that opposes Trump, has now come out
and said Trump is the Confederacy's second
president. This is a Republican group which
put out a statement where they said, We never
imagined when we named our initiative to defeat
the reelection of Trump, the Lincoln Project,
that the president would go as far as honoring
the Confederate generals who fought against
the United States to preserve slavery and
uphold white supremacy, for all intents and
purposes. Trump today became the Confederacy's
second president. We cannot allow this. And
then they go on to say we need help from Republicans
to remove Donald Trump in November. Strange
times, but I believe the decision by NASCAR
is the correct one. Whatever their reasons
for doing it. And it's probably a mix of understanding
the way society is going, combined with the
fact that it's probably a a bad PR move to
continue having these flags displayed.
They did ultimately come to the right decision.